ever so often something happens that in
that lets me know that I have a long
career ahead of me that there will
always be room for this show and our
advice we posted a simple little thing
on Facebook this morning that I've set a
thousand times and on Instagram and some
of you have gone absolutely ape you have
lost your ever-loving minds parents this
was the post don't encourage your kids
to take out student loans encourage them
to make plans to go to a school where
cash can be paid for college academics
are important but they do not cause you
to be successful we all know
highly-educated
broke people now that's a fairly
consistent Dave Ramsey message that is
not new information to the universe but
I got to tell you some of you when you
are on social media lose your minds some
of the meanest people on the planet seem
to hang out at Facebook and a few of
them on Instagram and the rest of them
are on Twitter oh my gosh y'all calm
yourself
chill your little self down I've been
called names
I've been harassed I'm the only thing
I'm short on it's a couple of death
threats and that'll probably happen by
the end of day because I dared to say
that you can go to college without that
I'm out of touch I don't know anything
about the real world oh and my favorite
is you know listen I understand if you
don't have hope how you feel trapped I
understand that but you need to guard
your tongue and you need to guard your
spirit because when you get crazy like
this it makes you look stupid
so I mean who can seriously afford to
pay cash at 17 or 18 years old sarcasm
sarcasm sarcasm you know and it just got
I mean it's just I don't want to read
them all but that my favorite was not
every this is what you always throw out
especially liberals right not everyone
is born with privilege to be able to pay
for their college education there are
ways to do it cheaper but this is a very
privileged mindset darling the only
privilege I have is the privilege of
having common sense and the ability to
do mathematics that's the privilege that
I have it is not a privileged mindset it
is a mathematical freaking fact but man
you guys are going nuts some of your
because I dared to say that you should
not be part of the one and a half
trillion dollar Student Loan debacle and
that you can become educated without
going into debt it happens you people
are angry some of your people are really
nuts so let's just do a little basic
math okay just a little basic math
here's the actual statistical facts
today not that I'm out of touch not that
I don't do other real world works you
ought to come out here and visit us
little people Oh bless your stupid butt
little hearts some of you are absolutely
buttholes man seriously pull your head
out of your butt and do some math this
is really not that hard
here's the deal the average State
University annual tuition in America
today in-state tuition
today is nine thousand five hundred
dollars a year the average person
delivering pizzas five nights a week in
America today makes fifteen hundred
dollars a month at their night job lots
of my uber drivers as I get in their
cars across America are making fifteen
hundred to two thousand dollars a month
as their side hustle doing over some of
them it's their full-time gig so let's
do a little math okay let me help you
with this because some of you the sixth
grade was education higher education for
you apparently $9,500
versus 1,500 a month 1500 a month is
18,000 a year can you pay 9,000 if you
have 18,000 is this hard for you can you
pay 9,000 if you have 18,000 yes can you
find if listen you should not be in
college if you cannot successfully
deliver a pizza you should not be in
college if you can't successfully drive
for uber that is not privileged stupid
but woman that is mathematical facts now
can you live at home and drive pizzas
and have enough to pay your tuition and
your books easily times 2 but you have
to work while you're in school and
you're not doing minimum wage flopper
whopping jobs if you're gonna flop
whoppers you probably can't pull this
off you actually have to use your brain
you could make $25 an hour cleaning
people's toilets get you a leaf blower
rich people are afraid of leaves they
will pay you serious money kid knocked
on my front door a couple years ago had
a pressure washer in tow wanted to
pressure wash my driveway and ceiling he
walked away with 1,500 bucks a day later
now you had some cost of goods sold a
little bit of equipment invested one day
you know why I gave him a job he's not
gonna try and play cash for college all
right I need my driveway seal bond is
sealed after he did that just seal it
buddy I'm doing it we're doing this yeah
you can pressure wash you can wash
people's dogs
you can walk people's dogs you can clean
people's toilets you can drive for uber
and you can work your way through a
state school while living at home or you
could actually live in the dorm and do
that because you got another nine or ten
thousand dollars to work with here in a
year but you are working instead of
playing beer pong in your off hours when
you're not in class you're working
we faked my GPA will go down your GPA
goes down more from beer pong than it
does from working you can't hang out at
the frat house all the time when I
couldn't move the college experience
we're not talking about the college
experience doofus we're talking about an
education here getting an education a
four-year degree in four freaking years
you can go to Community College for less
than that your first two years in the
state of Tennessee Community College is
free it's a couple of other states it is
and it's dadgum near free in a lot of
other states get your first two years
out of the way for half of that or less
you can even go to a private university
which is thirty four thousand seven
hundred a year but now you got to start
making some real money College choice
and being willing to work at a job that
is not minimum wage that is not your
life goal so you can make some money is
how you go to college debt-free
so before you draw out your sarcasm you
mean women on Facebook my god dollar
mean seriously it's unbelievable
before you draw your little sword before
you come to a gunfight with a knife you
better be careful because I'll take you
down a notch this is the Dave Ramsey
show